depuis quinze jours maintenant et le
second confinement la culture elle aussi
est à l'arrêt plus de concerts plus de
spectacle plus de pièces de théâtre
pourtant au centre chorégraphique
national de tours les résidences de
création sont maintenus un danseur
tourangeau il ya d'ailleurs pris ses
quartiers d'automne
romain belleville
[Musique]
en résidence au cnt jimmy du ciel
prépare sa future pièce fer avec nicolas
richard régisseur de la compagnie sol
foule
le danseur et chorégraphe peut créer et
répéter travailler le 1er confinement a
mis à l'arrêt la création le deuxième un
style des doutes on est partagé et à
côté on est content on peut travailler
donc ça fait du bien ça soulage
et il ya un autre côté on se dit très
bien mais du coup pour qu'on travaille
pour quoi pour qui on sait pas encore
les salles de spectacle les théâtres
sont fermés les cours de danse qu'ils
enseignent sont annulés jimmy du ciel a
même dû annuler le sol winter classe en
février 2021
cela fait cinq ans que ça existe et je
décidé de ne pas le faire parce que je
sais que le confinement d'être bloqués
comme ça c'était compliqué à mettre en
place et j'ai eu la preuve là nous
sommes confinés on sait pas pour combien
de temps donc si je m'étais lancé dans
cette préparation je l'aurais fait
sûrement points et j'aurais perdu à la
fois de l'argent du temps et de
l'énergie pour nicolas le régisseur
général de la compagnie cette semaine de
résidence au cnt se sont tout simplement
ces derniers jours de travail programmé
en 2020 on espère qu'on reprendra
peut-être en décembre peut-être mes cd
peut-être et avec n'est peut-être pas
très loin on m'apprend l'instant
l'avenir est assez vague pour le travail
en espérant que re se reprennent assez
vite à ce que bah si l'on est obligé
d'aller voir ailleurs
il faut venir manger les questions
restent en suspens et quand un jour les
spectacles reprendront nicolas richard
en est certain tous les artistes tous
les intermittents du moment ne pourront
reprendre leurs activités normales